hey everyone that's Steven Chu up with
Collider and I'm here with the good
folks behind captive state how you guys
doing very well thanks good to see um
the only reason that Collider gets to be
here is because we have some awesome
sponsors South by Southwest is what we
call expensive to cover so I just want
to give a huge thank you to all of our
sponsors which you can see here on our
table I'm a big fan of the tequila
that's right there I had a margarita
yesterday and this is off the rails but
it was really good yeah never to movie
but by the way it was real good and I'm
not just saying that as like because
they're our sponsor
yeah like the margarita was legit nice I
just again I'm off the rails I'm so
sorry it's early in the morning so
before we get into captive state I
definitely want a I'm a fan of your work
and I've been waiting but you've been
attached to a few things that just
didn't go and as a fan I am curious
before we get into captive state so
woody what exactly happened I have to
start with what happened with gambit
that and then we also you were on halo
for a little bit yeah I mean look it
happens often with with projects
unfortunately which there's any number
of reasons I mean a gambit was
ultimately you know I'll be honest about
it
Fantastic Four came out did not do very
well for Fox they decided to lower our
budget we were 12 weeks out we couldn't
recover the script needed a huge amount
of rewriting in order to fit that budget
and and ultimately you know
powers-that-be chose not to go down that
road so the film didn't happen sorry but
um and then of course
whatever happened after me with other
directors I have no idea of what I do
know is that Channing Tatum and his
producing partner Ari Karen and had an
amazing had an amazing idea of what that
movie was gonna be and Josh said I'm at
the writer as well it was it was
terrific I mean it was really exciting
kind of I sort of Godfather with with
mutants set in the world of New Orleans
with different gangs and
I was thinking it was gonna be like a
heist movie yeah of a sword I mean it
was a period film it dealt with the 70s
up until the present day and it and it
it was about kind of mutant gangs and
the notion of what it means to belong
tribalism in the kind of in this sort of
Bayou like sort of environment and
swamps of New Orleans so it would have
been a lot of fun I don't know I know
that Channing sort of worked on the
scripts and making it into a more of a
romantic comedy I think which I read and
it was great it was very different to
what I was involved in
but now Disney have have the reins so I
don't know what that plans up it's so
interesting to me because I never viewed
for me as an outsider and I'm so sorry
we're gonna get into captain state but
I've never viewed gambit has such a
strong character to carry his own movie
that I was always wondering because I
heard what the budget was gonna be and
it was well over a hundred million from
or wasn't know oh the one you were gonna
make yeah I'm completely oh I read that
too that someone said it was one hundred
and fifty million it was not okay so I
will then it's that's even more
surprising to me then because the
superhero genre Fantastic Four was an
anomaly generally speaking the superhero
genre is the most popular on the planet
so it seems like no matter what the
movie is it performs it's crazy it was a
really good script to you know some of
those movies can sort of be ultimately
be impressive but not be the belt on
historian no one was good yeah Joshua's
great was Grant I mean look this is
probably getting in the weeds too much
but it's it is interesting to talk about
it's like invariably what happens with
that kind of process of filmmaking if if
people don't have their ducks in a row
is they'll throw it at the wall they'll
then realize it's not sticking and
they'll then spend 150 million dollars
to get it right now as a filmmaker I've
been through that process and it's
really hard to then end up with a piece
of work that actually functions and has
a cohesive story to it and I think you
know we were in a place both chaning me
read
the producers where we didn't want to
have to go through that experience we
wanted to you know set out to make a
particular film and and deliver on that
Angier and so you know the whole process
of reshoots and all of that stuff we
didn't want to go down that road
it's interesting I've spoken to a lot of
filmmakers like it happened with Chris
McQuarrie on the mission movie on I
think both mission movies but especially
the recent one where the production
halfway through you know Tom broke his
ankle they have to stop and he was able
to go in the editing room see all the
footage they had and continue writing
yeah and see what they needed what it
was working and then you know the movie
spectacular but one of the reasons even
Chris will say is because we had that
break in the middle yeah I could look at
everything and I so wish more films had
the ability and budget to take like two
weeks in the middle and just look at
everything
isn't that the Japanese is that is that
where they do it that way often why he
does that I mean a lot of Asian
filmmakers do it what do you Alan does
it I mean it's it's you shoot a bit you
stand down you know it's we were talking
about this with a friend of ours the
other day who's an independent filmmaker
who's just made this really interesting
film about Ted Kaczynski and he's shot
it over an entire year like shot a
little bit stops you know and and what
it's allowed him to do is understand the
movie and cut things try things out
rewrite and and the studio system
doesn't really allow for that because it
costs two hundred thousand dollars a day
to be on ER on a studio set the other
thing is that I think that often in the
in the studio format you know there's so
much on the line that they don't allow
you know a single creative mind to drive
that process so there's sort of focus
groups and lots of people who come in
and it feels like it's more of a panic
situation where they're you know
spending the money at the end to sort of
band-aid over problems instead of the
other thing is it listen to changing
landscape out there right now but you
know when you're aiming at all four
quadrants you're not gonna hit any right
do you want to aim at the audience and I
want to get it to halo but let's jump
into captive State so I got to know B
just because it's a good tangent because
yeah this is
my kind of movie like I I really enjoyed
the film and I'm a big fan of sci-fi and
this is like it you're aiming at me
you're not aiming at four quadrants with
this movie like oh you hit me dead
center and I'm like [ __ ] yes you know
what I mean so um one of the things is
and I think it's important to say this
this is not some 100 million dollar
movie this was made clearly on a budget
and so talk a little bit about you guys
putting this thing together for a budget
and what you wanted to do with it
yeah I mean first of all I think you
you're right and this shouldn't be a
hundred million dollar movie I think it
would have been wholly inappropriate to
make a film like this for that amount of
money because you're right it's it's not
diluting certain choices in order to
appeal to as many people as possible
that said you know we as filmmakers love
to tell stories
for an audience there's a reason why in
a cinema there is you know a stadium
seating the idea of getting as many
people to come to witness a story and be
part of the storytelling is is massively
appealing we're not making it for a
chosen few but there are tropes to
storytelling both in particular in genre
that the the hero's journey for example
the people in the mainstream have a
tendency to want to follow and have an
expectation especially with a film like
this that that's how it's gonna play out
so you know there's many many other
aspects to this film but as an example
we've to hold an ensemble story it's a
hyper narrative we follow multiple
characters through this one landscape
and we don't necessarily therefore have
a protagonist a set protagonist we we
leave what we think is our protagonist
behind for twenty five minutes whilst we
go off and follow other characters
they're all part of the same story and I
think that's really exciting to be able
to do but it's it's really something
that you can only really do when you
have a creative freedom I think and
speaking for myself I'm not necessarily
a straight down the line genre person
the aspect of genre that really
interests me is subverting genre or you
know doing something different with
genre so definitely when we were working
on this together that was sort of always
my approach as I was saying you guys
made this obvious
on a budget talk a little bit about the
importance of finding where that you can
actually quote-unquote spend the money
do you know what I mean because when you
have only so much of it you have to
pinpoint what are the shots that I
really need to show an alien or at least
that's what I'm thinking yeah yeah well
I mean it with this this film we were
incredibly lucky because it rarely
happens and it may never happen again
but the idea of being able to write a
script put it in front of me few people
and they go yeah we want to make that
film too and then being able to go out
and make it is a rare situation and we
were in that situation with this with
this film and when participants said yes
we would like to make this film with you
we were in pre-production two three
months later now the great thing about
that is is the momentum is immense the
challenging thing is getting the film
ready on time and being able to really
prepare and and plan and I'd say that
you know preparation is everything and
and and goes back to what we were saying
earlier about having time time to shoot
time to really kind of work in multiple
locations rather than building
everything on a stage which probably
gives you more shooting time but
aesthetically changes the nature of the
film and for us we wanted this to be
grounded so we have over 40 locations in
this film we have a hundred speaking
parts we were traveling around Chicago
in the middle of winter with a pretty
stripped-down unit for a film of this
ambition in order to sort of try and
give it a scale that is grounded and
plausible well I think also just you
know to speak to your process if I may
say how it is for you that I think you
approach sort of everything from the
indie sensibility that you know you had
from the very beginning that you've kind
of come up with which is it really
matters to you how you spend the money
and you really think about that and so
you know endless conversations you know
I've heard him have or had on things
like this where it's like you know can
you achieve the same dramatic impact
from a close-up you know of somebody's
face and a sound effect of a giant
explosion or do you need to actually
blow
the building you know and oftentimes you
can get the same impact from the
close-up on someone's face and the sound
effect and if you can do that then in
some ways that's like I'm more of a
creative achievement if that makes sense
or it feels good to really you know pick
your moments yeah yeah I was gonna say
one of the things about this is having
certain actors and key roles really
matters because it pulls you and makes
it basically where I'm going at is I'm a
huge John Goodman fan and so having him
in this movie and his performance and it
really carries a lot of weight so what
was the secret of getting him was he
gung-ho well what was that initial
meeting like have you ever met him yes I
have actually okay
did you remember yeah he was very he was
when I saw him he was loud and very like
there yeah he's really interesting jump
because he's a contradiction he can be
very shy and retiring and quiet and then
he can be very boolean and bombastic and
and and big and it's the same across all
aspects of his personality I think and
it's what makes him a really interesting
actor I think he he sort of has has a
sort of a constant kind of he travels
emotionally a lot and so but it stripped
down he's an actor's actor he's very
straightforward he he works to his gut
and his instincts so I work with him on
the gambler just for a couple of days
actually and and so we we'd really not
got to know each other that well but we
I think we I personally really enjoyed
working with him and he came in and kind
of knocked it out of the park basically
with this 10 page monologue and he was
very sort of amenable and up for doing
different things and trying different
things and I think the scene actually in
The Gambler
was set in a sports bar and we said well
let's put you in a spa cuz I just saw at
the time he was he was a much larger man
than he is now and I thought this this
mountain of a man would be kind of
amazing visually in this spa with a
towel around his neck and you know
sweating heavily and you know his
presence would have was magnificent and
many actors who would have gone nope not
gonna do that and he went for it and
loved it and
so I went back to him with this when we
were working on the character we wanted
to develop this idea of a man full of
contradictions he's on the one hand a
man who believes in law and order but on
another hand he's a collaborator he's a
man who's morally bankrupt who's doing
very bad things and seen very bad things
he's a man who goes to see a prostitute
yet at the same time he has this clearly
very genuine relationship with her and
and genuine feelings for her so I needed
an actor that you could sort of in a way
projects many things onto and and you're
not necessarily going to say he's our
antagonist or he's our protagonist and
there's not many of his stature that can
do that you know he that's why I use a
character acting more than a movie style
even though he is also a movie star if
you know what I mean
ultimately the editing room is the final
rewrite I'm curious how things changed
in the editing room and did you show the
movie to people get feedback and are
like oh my god I can't believe we missed
that I mean just to say this I felt so
lucky to be doing this with him because
often as the writer you don't get to be
involved in all of those aspects of the
process so to really sort of as you said
be involved in not only the initial
writing but the rewriting through the
editing was was such a pleasure I feel
like I'm massively helpful as well to
have to have my writer in the room with
my editor working with my our editor
Andrew groves and and even our DP Alex
dissing hope I mean every aspect and
that's the great thing about making a
film at this scale is everyone is coming
at it from a quite a quite as sort of
what's the word sort of altruistic
Sensibility there there everyone's sort
of united under this notion of making
the very best film possible and and
that's not to say when you're working on
bigger budgets people don't feel that
but invariably it's a job it's a finite
job and you then move on to the next
thing whereas this was a vocation for
many of us in and so to be able to sit
in a room with our with our backers with
the studio with the filmmakers and and
kind of honestly say that's working this
is not working and we need to fix it and
so yeah there was a lot there was a lot
that changed in the Edit but from the
first film I made
the escapists they remember Joe Walker
the editor of that film he and I
completely rewrote the film in the Edit
in many ways structurally we really
started to change things on a wall
because it wasn't working and and it was
the same with this in many ways we had
to sort of find refined it and also
because the plot is quite complex and it
hinges on the audience you know being
aware of certain things but not being
aware of other things and there's always
that question of are you giving them too
much so they are way ahead of you or
you're not giving them enough and
they're going I don't know what the hell
is going on and so it was really
important to show the movie - we sort of
had this brain trust of people in in
Hudson where we live and you know would
common and screen it for them and have
them say you know I don't get that or I
think this and you realize you know it's
it's so important to get that kind of
feedback say okay we we think we're
saying something here that is not
happening yet or we also had test
screenings as well which is a whole
other story but that's for sure well you
know it's interesting is that I've heard
a lot of filmmakers say that they hate
the test screening process and I've
heard other filmmakers that are they
revere it because ultimately you know
when you've seen it a thousand times
you've lost all perspective you have to
show the audience yeah no I agree but if
it's if the question is is is that test
screening full of as you said if it's
not a four-quadrant movie that's always
the issue so if you get a bunch of views
in the test screening and you're sort of
talking to people who are your audience
that's great if you get quadrant there
was a knight rayearth once who said who
actually put his finger on it way he
said the test screening is a little bit
like everyone sitting around a table
with a bottle of wine and tasting that
wine and everyone's gonna have a
different opinion about how that wine
tastes but if you add water and you add
more and more water
everyone's eventually gonna say it
tastes the same and you can dilute a
film as a result of that very true but
that what I would say and I think that's
what test scoring I have my problems
with in terms of putting it to a random
audience I think there's a lot to be got
from people's feedback because of course
there are gonna be some who are in line
with your thinking there are gonna be
others who totally out there but you
know if five people tell you you're
drunk
then you're drunk do you know
well I think it's also important like if
you if the if the question is did you
have confusion about this scene and you
know and everyone says no or if everyone
says yes well then you have an answer
there but yeah but I but listen I agree
and I think that ultimately you guys
made this on a budget so it's not like
you're aiming at four quadrants and I
think that's the key I think it's when
movies are made for two hundred million
dollars yes you know that's a whole
different beast right Neil Blomkamp's
district 9 I I think you know was made
on it's not dissimilar budget and
ultimately you know when went global in
terms of its reach and and and its box
office so I'm not suggesting for a
second that will we're gonna be
following in those footsteps but um but
I think there's an opportunity if you
can do something that people tap into in
the moment and it's a little bit
different and I would say that as a
sci-fi you know we're dealing with an
alien occupation not an invasion with
that in itself is a different approach
to things but also just totally you find
the right groove at the particular
moment in time that the film comes out I
think you can get a swell of support
that goes beyond your your core audience
and that's what we always hope for
whether that happens you know totally I
also think that nowadays so many people
watch things and it's important to
realize so many people watch things when
it's streaming now you know it's it's
just a different world as you know I'm
and I know you guys must be you know for
me the movie theater is like you know
the church the temple you know
the idea of watching it at home is not
for me but that's where a lot of people
watch it on their phones on their phones
you know if I know it's crazy before I
run out of time I totally have to just
real quick so what happened with halo I
was so excited to see your take on this
I'm still excited I I mean I'm you know
I think look I mean in a nutshell to
sort of put it in is succinctly way as
possible I got involved I knew very
little about halo same ways and you very
little about Planet of the Apes actually
when I got involved and I kind of steep
myself in the mythology and began to
realize how much incredible literature
there was and the depth of the
storytelling and
it all stacked up for me there was an
incredible foundation to the
storytelling so I was it was gangbusters
III was super excited in short I think
if I had sort of come at it from an
earlier perspective in the in the in the
building of it then perhaps it would
have gone differently but as a director
of a TV show it's quite hard to sort of
in a way become a creative architect of
a show and I think in a way I was never
gonna be that and and that's fine
because there are really many talented
people involved in in that show who are
doing that job and so it became clear
that there was gonna be more time needed
and I'm talking you know some months if
not years to to align you know as you
probably know it's massively ambitious
so the budget for that needs to really
align with the scripts and they were
still we were still kind of working on
that but it ultimately wasn't under my
watch to be able to find that alignment
so there was a choice made by Showtime
which was essentially to push things and
if I had been perhaps the showrunner of
the of the film then I would have stayed
on that journey for two three years but
as a director of a finite number of
episodes there's there's other things I
really want to do so I was very sad to
have to leave but I basically it wasn't
within the framework that I had
originally signed up for so one of the
things about halo is as a fan it's such
an interesting and cool world that I
think is when it took one of those rare
things that actually think I will work I
think as a series 8 or 10 episode you
know I'm a huge fan of the eight or 10
episode season and I think halo is like
one of those perfect things that you if
you do it right and you have the budget
and you have the right story to tell
each year yeah you can I mean this could
be something cool in it also it has a
cool title yeah all you need really
titles really important yeah yeah you
know yeah exactly as many things but by
the way you know something nowadays and
I say this all the time to people if you
have a bad title what are you thinking
it's like
if you have people it's like going to a
website you have like a millisecond to
get a reaction yeah yeah so like if you
have a bad title I'm like what you done
yeah I mean I'm sure we've all been in a
cinema where have you seen the trailer
and gone that's kind of interesting and
then the title comes up and it's the
same thing with kids names he's got to
be really careful with that cuz man if
you whiffed that at the beginning yeah
your kid is screwed right I got my
parents went with Steve I was [ __ ] I
wasn't calling Matt like the worst one
ever but yeah I mean you know so
Hildegarde or something no that's like
God you better be cool if you're calling
right before one of my last things I
like I said I am a fan of your work and
uh so what's cooking I believe you have
something I wrote it down oh man what
did I write I wrote down something the
storm King storm king is that actually
going what are you working on next yeah
so so we're writing storm king it's for
Jeff Robin off at Studio 8 who used to
be the the guy running for Warner
Brothers and and it really interesting
studio guy and and really into kind of
similar to captive state kind of putting
out original pieces of work within the
genre realm and and I think that's
really exciting 10 10 years ago those
were dying on the vine there were not
many around and and I think streaming
has begun to bring back the middle
budget movie but there's still that
space in the theatrical world to be
making those films and I speaking for
myself and I think for both of us
it's incredibly fortunate that we have
that opportunity whether we have it in 5
10 years from now where you know all
cinema become aside the franchise or or
heavily independent filmmaking you know
the middle ground movie is is that rare
beast and so so storm king is that for
sure
can you say what it's about or it's it's
it's a it's a gauntlet story I I'm a
massive fan of Walter Hill why wouldn't
you been who would not be unless if I
know Walt hill yeah I think he's
incredibly underrated well he's not
underrated he's actually rated as he
should be but I'm
I love his form of storytelling where
he's doing something with genre but
ultimately telling story from the human
perspective and that's certainly what
storm Kings intending to be but it's
said in a it's said in a world that is
not unlike arts but but that much
different and it's a gauntlet film I've
always wanted to tell a story about the
coming together of a team to carry off
one single event and it's that I'm very
very curious you gave me a little but
not a lot does it have to do with like a
hurricane because a storm like you know
about I'll leave it be I don't want to I
don't make you yeah I don't want to get
you in trouble my last thing getting
back into captive state did with with a
finite budget you obviously can only
shoot so much but did you have a much
longer first cut do you have a lot of
deleted scenes or is it pretty much on
on the screen so much I mean Rupert was
just saying the other day that it's so
true they shot you know he shot so
quickly and they shot so much and I mean
hindsight is 20/20 but manure more time
to spend on some of the things that
ended up there and you know less time
spent on many things that didn't but at
the same time as we said with a story
this complicated yeah that's part of the
process I think it's it's sort of when
we when we wrote the scripts we we knew
we were always going to be looking at
creating an ambitious story from
multiple perspectives a hyper narrative
you know following one character into
the space of another leaving that
character behind following the next
character and ultimately creating this
spiders weapon the challenge with that
is allowing the audience to not only
sort of immerse themselves in the story
but also empathize with the characters
and understand the plot and in
particular it was the first act that we
had to do the most work and post because
we needed to get the engine of the story
going with all these different
characters and jumping around as an
audience member you're having to to
really follow what's going on but once
the engine sort of kicks in and the
second act happens and in the case of
our film the heist as it were starts to
kick off that's where we felt like the
film started to lift
and so it was finding the best way
possible to tell the story in the
beginning the architect of the
architecture of the story and that's
yeah that's probably where we have the
most scenes cut or shift because it's
hard to set up so many characters and
you feel like you're sort of starting
and then starting yeah starting and then
if you always tell people if you want to
see it if you've never seen Cloud Atlas
which i think is a masterpiece the
opening to that film why wouldn't you
love that know that people who don't
they're all idiots the first the opening
15 minutes is so dense with character
yeah but I
once you see it a second time but you
shouldn't have to do but it's so dense
that the second time you see it man that
movie is brilliant yeah I can I just
want to bring up Cloud Atlas anytime I
can so I'm sorry I I think I think I
mean it's a profile I found it a
profound profound movie watching
experience it was sort of it's a
masterpiece religious since I was like
every aspects ok this there's aspects of
it that are quite arched but that's
classic which I'll ski sort of sort of
tone in many ways but like the music
that Tom to I commute ik and it is yeah
I need to end the interview with you but
I could talk about cloud cloud Alice for
like two hours
I mean seriously like the movies amazing
Congrats on captive state I'm so happy
you guys got to come in our studio thank
you again to our sponsors to supper
sweet and to everybody thank you thank
you have a great day thanks team
you